hello everybody today we're going to be
walking you through the Explorer's guide
to biology site showing our content
where you can find it all and also the
functionalities that accompany our
content on the site
and I will be going through multiple
sections of the site as we go through
this orientation so the first thing that
I'd like to do is just walk you through
the home page so this is the home page
that you will see if you are not logged
into your account as either a learner or
an educator
at any point if you would like to return
to this home page you can click on the
xbio icon here in the top left of any of
the screens that will be on today
so in this homepage you can see there's
a brief orientation video that you can
watch if you would like there's some
brief descriptions of the project itself
and then how you can register for either
a learner account or an educator account
and we'll go through that once we finish
going through this home page here
so this top navigation is the main way
that you're going to be navigating
through the site and we'll go through
each one of those tabs in just a bit but
first we'll talk a little bit about the
home page so on the home page there's
also an option to navigate through the
different sections in this explore our
content area down here if you go below
the Explorer content section you can see
that we have a list of our authors here
these aren't all of our authors but you
can click view all here to see a list of
all of our authors their bios as well as
some of the bio videos
below that we have a video of the day
and this is just a random sampling of
one of the videos that we have on our
site it changes daily and but you do
have the option to watch that video
here on the home page if you would like
to
if you're new to X bio we just have an
option for learning more about the
project learning more about our content
our team and then also some information
for educators there
again we have some information on how
you can register for an educator as an
educator and I will go through that in
just a second we have an option for a
feedback form here if you have any
feedback on the project or the content
we we always love to hear from folks so
we'd appreciate that feedback another
option for giving feedback is there will
always be this give us feedback button
here down in the bottom left and you can
click on that at just your first name
um and then your feedback here and then
you can click submit and that will go
straight to us so we appreciate any
feedback that you all have
we also have the option to subscribe to
our monthly newsletter here we just had
this information
um that we'd like you to fill out and
then you can
um click subscribe here and then at the
bottom in our footer there's
um multiple ways that you can navigate
around the site as well but that's
fairly straightforward so I won't walk
through all those because I'll be doing
that up at the top here
so the first thing that we'll talk about
is how to register for an account and
that will be you there were multiple
ways in the home page but the most
straightforward way is that you will
always see this registrate register
button up here in the top right so if
you click on this register button it
will ask for information that you can
fill out here your email your username
um that you can pick and then a you'll
create a password
there are guidelines for this password
at the um with this little
uh question mark button
confirm your password Here
and then there are three boxes that you
can check down here below the
information that you have just entered
the first is agreeing to our terms of
use
that will allow you to actually create
an account you must agree to a terms of
use to be able to create an account
the second box is you can sign up for
the newsletter here so that's an
automatic sign up it just uses the
information that you input in your
registration form
and then the last option is for you to
create an educator account and we'll go
through that in just a second but if you
are a learner and you are not an
educator and you just like to use the
resources on the site which gives you
access to everything except for our
educator uh resources that are
specifically for educators and you need
an educated or account to access then
that's all you need to do you can just
create your learner account here there's
no further verification you will
immediately have access to everything
those who don't register still have
access to all of our content but they
don't have access to a lot of the
functionalities such as my Collections
and annotations and things that we'll go
over in just a second
if you are an educator and you would
like to sign up as an educator account
then you just click this educated button
and you'll see that your submission
button has now changed to provide
further details so if you click on this
provide further details button you have
three different options for how you can
show us that you are an educator and
these aren't very stringent on our end
we basically are just verifying that you
are teaching other folks in some
capacity it doesn't necessarily have to
be officially at a university it could
just be a group of adult Learners that
get together
um and would like to teach
each other about biology the first
option is you can provide any URL for
example you know a bio for a university
or
um you know a organizational page that
shows that you are in the education
field the second option is you can
upload an image which could be you know
your University ID or something like
that and the third option is just to
write a description of why you would
like an educator account again just one
or two sentences would be just fine so
once you provided one of these three
options then you can click this sign up
for X bio button that will send us a
verification email we will take a look
at the information you provided and
verify you as an educator we do that
daily so it shouldn't take more than 24
hours to get your educator status
verified if you take a look at this and
you decide you would rather not provide
this information you can always just
register as a learner here
so that's it for registration
so now we'll go say you have registered
and you can do the page so we'll go back
to the home page here
um you always have the option to log in
which is right next to the registration
button
click here this just gives a brief
overview of what creating an account
gives you
um so you can add your email that you
use to register and then your password
and that will allow you to log into the
site once you've logged in this is the
home page that you will see you'll see a
button for X bio Collections and then
also my Collections and we'll go into
that in just a second but the rest of
the home page is the same so we have the
navigation down here the authors
video of the day that sort of thing
so the next thing we'll talk about is
our x-bio Collections and the
collections are where most of our
content lives we have lots of different
types of content but this is where the
larger pieces such as narratives and key
experiments which is our big educational
pieces live and we'll go into more of
what those are but you have multiple
ways that you can access these x-bio
collections you can either use this
large button here you can click on the
collections tab up top or you can see
that if you hover over the collections
tab you have an option to visit specific
collections including my collection
um
directly rather than just going to the
collections homepage but if you do click
on either this button or this top
navigation then it will take you to the
collections homepage which just shows
you the the collections that we have at
this point we have a cell biology
collection and a genetics collection uh
you can see that in this drop down we
also have a neuroscience collection
that's coming soon we're developing
those Neuroscience pieces right now and
that should be uh released pretty soon
so that's exciting
but if you'd like to investigate our
genetics collection you can either
access it via this drop down or from the
home page the collections home page you
can just click on one of these buttons
and that will bring you to the
collection home page here and you can
see that there are two different types
of content in these collections we have
narratives which are larger pieces that
cover a large concept within biology for
example the structure of DNA or plant
genetics you can see some of those
narratives and all of these narratives
will be labeled with this green
narrative button on the icon for that
specific piece we also have key
experiments which tell the story of a
specific experiment that led to a
significant Discovery in biology and all
of these key experiments will be labeled
with this purple key experiment tab here
um you can also organize these by
narrative here so if you click this
narrative tab it will display just the
narratives or key experiment you can see
just the key experiments here the other
option to view these uh pieces within a
collection are looking at them with the
list view this will show the same
pieces that were on the previous page
but with a short description of what
those are so right now we're just
looking at the key experiments if you go
back to all it will show
um everything it'll revert back
to the image section but then you can
click list and again see all of the
short descriptions for each one of the
content pieces
uh the other thing that I'd like to
point out on this page is you can
navigate directly between collections uh
via this drop down menu here you can see
we're in the genetics collection now but
if we'd like to navigate to the cell
biology collection you can just click
that and that will take you directly to
the cell biology collection homepage
so these are how the X bio collections
work the other thing that I would like
to talk about before we get into the
nitty-gritty of what these content
pieces look like
is the my collections function so once
you've logged in you have the option to
create
um your own collection which basically
allows you to add either whole content
pieces specific text from content pieces
images and videos from within the
content pieces and bio dictionary terms
which we'll we'll go over in just a bit
but you can create your own collection
um with any of those types of content
and so you can see here in the list view
there's this add collection option so if
you'd like to add the structure of DNA
piece to your collection you can just
click this button if you're on the image
or tile view these little pluses here
are what allow you to add these content
pieces to your collection
so we'll go over what is in the my
collection section in just a bit but I
wanted to point that out because you'll
be seeing these pluses as we go through
the content pieces and I wanted to let
you all know what those were for those
were for adding things to your
collection specifically
so what we'll do now is walk through one
of the content pieces just to show you
what these content pieces look like and
[Music]
um
how you and the different
functionalities that you can use within
the content pieces themselves so to
access a contents piece all you have to
do is click on the icon there and that
takes you to the summary page and on the
summary page you'll see the title of the
content piece the author the author's
image you can view the video bio for the
author if you would like and then a
brief description of the author's bio
we also have a summary of the piece
itself so this is basically just a brief
overview of what is included in this
content piece and then finally you can
download a PDF of this content piece
with this download PDF option on the
summary page here um if you'd like to
work with this content piece offline or
provide it to students offline
then you can see down here there's two
buttons on the summary page you can see
the go to learning overview page which
is the first thing that we'll do and in
this learning overview it gives just a
basic description of
what is included in the content piece
the big Concepts that are there bio
dictionary terms used and you can see
that all of these biodictionary terms
are linked and so if you click on any of
these biodictionary terms it will pop up
and show you the image Associated
sometimes there's also a video
associated with it and then the
definition for that term and that's
these terms are linked to in the text as
well
um there are some terms and Concepts
Concepts explained you can see that
again you can click on any of the linked
terms some of these we don't have links
to yet but we will as we go through
so each of these narratives we're
looking at a narrative right now are
organized into different sections you
have the introduction section which
gives you an introduction to the concept
you have the first part which is the
journey to Discovery and that covers
several key experiments that uh
that were influential in establishing
the current knowledge base that we have
in the field and That'll Walk folks
through how those the thought processes
behind those experiments how those
experiments were done and how they
influenced the field today
um the second section is the knowledge
overview which really covers the nuts
and bolts of the knowledge that is
associated with this concept so for
example this Con this um narrative that
we're looking at right now is mutations
so this will be you know a lot of the
biological knowledge that is
um
that is key to understanding mutations
and it will also be presented in the
context of the experiments that were
talked about in the knowledge overview
section
the third part is our Frontiers section
and this covers
um one specific
area of current research that is
interesting in the field some of the
narratives or key experiments I'm sorry
some of the narratives will talk about
multiple different research areas that
are happening but we really tend to
focus on one of these and this is just
to give students an idea of what's going
on the research that's happening in the
field right now
um we there's also a closing thoughts
section which sort of summarizes
everything in the piece brings it all
back together we also have guided papers
that are a primary literature paper for
example this is the 1943 luria and
Delbert paper
um
that is annotated and what that means is
if you click on a download here you'll
see that the the paper itself pops up
but we have added notes or annotations
to this paper to help students
understand how to read scientific papers
what some sort of sticky Concepts in the
scientific paper mean or explain some
language that introductory biology
students may not be familiar with so
it's really designed to help students
that don't have a whole lot of
experience with primary literature
understand how to read through a
scientific paper and explain some of the
knowledge that is included in that
scientific paper so you always have the
option to download these papers you can
see that there are two of these guided
papers that are associated with this
content piece
um and then if there is an activity
associated with the content piece then
we'll also have this activity on this
learning overview page and you can click
this link to go to that activity
um we'll we'll talk about activities a
little bit more as we go through
so that's what's included on the
learning overview page and you can
navigate through the different sections
of the learning overview page on this
left-hand navigation all of these text
portions are links to the different
sections that we just went through on
the learning overview page
so from this learning overview page you
can either go back to the summary page
which is what we saw first that's the
that's what that's basically the home
page of the piece or you can go directly
to the narrative itself so we'll just go
back to the summary page because on this
page you remember there was a option to
go directly to the narrative if you
don't want to look over the learn the
learning overview page so if we click on
this go to narrative page it'll take us
to the narrative
and so just walking through some of the
navigation of how you can move through
these pieces on this left hand side what
we're looking at is the Explorer's
Compass you can see here it's
highlighted and it just gives you an
option to go through the different
sections within uh the narrative itself
and I'll walk through each one of these
sections as we go the other option in
this left-hand navigation is you can
look at all of the media that's
associated so the figures and videos so
you can see their figures here if you
would just like to see the figures you
can click on figures that will display
all of the figures in this content piece
you can also take a look at the videos
that are associated with these content
pieces and this is just a lot to allow
you to easily access any uh figure or
video that you find interesting or would
like to add to your collection or
something like that
um the another option that we have on
this left-hand navigation is annotations
so as you're going through
you can highlight specific pieces of
text so if you just highlight that text
you'll see that you have the option to
annotate highlight or add to your
collection
so if you decide to annotate that means
that you that specific piece of text
will show up as highlighted and we will
have a that piece of text that you've
highlighted up at the top you can add
your annotation into this box here and
then click done
that will then show up in your
annotation tab on the left hand side you
can edit that annotation with the pen
icon here or delete that annotation with
the trash can icon here you also have
the option to add this annotation to
your collection so if you annotate
something and you would like to have
that be part of your collection you can
use this button here
and you can see now that this annotation
is highlighted in blue uh the other
option that you have is to highlight a
portion of text
again this will pop up if you would like
to just highlight it but not add any
notes to it then you can do that as well
by just using the highlight button and
this highlighted portion of text will
show up in your annotation section here
as well but you can see that there's no
annotation associated with that below
this green line
finally if you'd like to highlight
something and directly add it to a
collection you can see that you have
your add to collections option here when
you click that it will give you a list
of all the collections that you've
created it will also give you an option
to create a new collection if you would
like to do that and then add it directly
to that new collection so if you'd like
to add it to a collection all you need
to do is click on this whichever
collection you would like to add it to
and then press save
so that's how you can use The annotation
function
and highlighting and adding things to
your collections
you can see that once you close that the
your annotations and highlights still
show up highlighted in blue so that that
will always show up highlighted in blue
once you log into your account for these
different content pieces the other
options we have to navigate in this left
navigation sections are we have a
section for the guided paper which you
saw in the learning overview page that's
also included at the bottom of this
narrative page as well
um and then finally we have educator
materials at the bottom as well which we
will go through uh these are only
accessible by uh folks who have
registered for an educator account those
who have registered for Learners learner
accounts will need to uh register as an
educator if they would like to access
that material
so as we're scrolling down through the
narrative piece itself you can see
um there's different links we reference
some of the other content pieces that we
have and these links will take you
directly to those content pieces if
you're interested in exploring those we
also have biodictionary terms that I
mentioned during learning overview so
these are linked to in the page as well
so you can see that that will bring up
the figure as well as the definition for
whatever that term is so that students
can easily access those
uh we also have links to some videos
that are not directly embedded in the
page
we also have internal links to different
sections within
um the content piece to quickly navigate
between the different sections
we have our figures which are linked to
directly so these are internal links
that you can see figure one if you click
on that it'll take you directly to
figure one
um with these figures you can see you
have the option to either add this to
your collection
um or you can download this image if you
would like to use it in a class or use
it for slide or use it for studying if
you are a learner
we also have videos here that play
directly in the page all these videos
have transcripts associated with them so
you can play the video with the
transcript or without the transcript you
can also add these videos directly to
your collection
um
we have clues that we go through the
only other thing I'd like to talk about
within the content itself are these
explorers questions so these are
questions that are designed to help
folks with just-in-time learning so as
they're reading through it sort of helps
students consider key Concepts and and
think about them critically as they go
through so you can see the question
displayed they can immediately view the
answer once again they can hide the
answer if they if they would like to
either share it or just not see that
answer anymore
foreign
so those are the main parts of the text
itself so I will go down to the bottom
I'll just click this guided paper icon
which takes you straight down to the
guided papers
so once again you can see these guide
papers that were on the learning
overview page for the short description
uh the option to download those guided
papers you can also add these guided
papers to your collection if you would
like to do that as well I'll open up
this explorers Compass again just to
show you the different sections that
we're going through below the guided
papers we have a references and
resources section
um which is provides references for
anything any literature that was uh
referenced within the content piece we
also have a list of some external
resources that are just additional
resources for those who would like to
learn more about specific content again
we have our activity here this is a
poisson simulator that I will go through
in just a bit
below that we have practice problems
which are ways where students can test
their knowledge some of these are
multiple choice some of these are short
answer and again you can view answers
here within these practice problems
and then the final thing is our educator
materials so again these are only
available I am currently logged in as an
educator so I can see these educator
materials but students who are not
logged in as educators will this will be
grayed out and that will be an option to
register as an educator if they'd if
they'd like to
um the educated materials that we have
here are some additional educator
assessment questions that Educators can
use in their teaching we also have some
suggested in-class active learning
activities and these are suggested
activities to help Educators actively
engage their students in the classroom
or virtually depending on the structure
of the class
foreign
so that is the main overview of the
content pieces the key experiments are
organized a little bit differently but
all of the functionalities and
navigation is the same within the key
experiments as it in as it is with the
narratives
so the last thing I'd like to talk about
within collections is how you navigate
your collection specifically so you know
I've given we've talked about all of
these different options for how to add
different things to your collection but
if you'd like to take a look at your
collections you can access that via this
drop down menu or again if you return to
the home page you have the option of
seeing your collection on this home page
as well so if we click on this my
collection it will show you all the
collections you've created I've only
created this one but if you click on
that collection it'll show you
everything that you've done if
everything that you've added to that
specific collection and these are
different types of content that I've
added some of its text some of its
images and that sort of thing you can
edit the title of your collection up
here with this edit
icon this pencil icon you can also see
specific types of content within your
collection so if you want to look at all
the images that you have added to your
collection then you can click on this
image same thing with videos or text
or whole collections themselves so this
will just break down into the different
types of content that you've added and
finally there's a biodictionary term
section here
uh you can if you'd like to see
everything again you can just go
navigate back to all if you click on any
one of these specific pieces it will
take you to that content piece directly
and you can see that was the highlighted
text that I added in my collection
and the advantage to my collections
is that
um one you can organize things for
yourself
two you can
um we'll go over the groups
functionality later and Educators can
share these collections with students
that they have invited into their group
um also so there's there's multiple ways
that you can use your collections you
can use it just for uh personal
reference for Designing lesson plans for
educators or for sharing collections
within the group's functionality later
on so the next thing that I will go
through are all of the remaining tabs up
here up top uh starting with the
biodictionary so you saw that each one
of the content pieces has biodationary
terms that are linked to within those
content pieces
all of those terms are included on this
biodictionary page and they're organized
alphabetically so you can navigate
VIA the alphabet just choosing a letter
for the term that it starts with you can
also just Browse by scrolling down and
you can see that they're once again
organized alphabetically
and each one of these terms if you hover
over it you see you have the option to
add this to your collection
um so if you have a specific term that
you'd like to add you can do that
once you click on one of these terms it
will show uh the image associated with
the term the text definition with the
term and then you also have the option
to download this as a PDF or add this to
your collection here you can also
enlarge the image if you would like to
take a look at the image itself via that
enlarge image button and then you can
navigate back to the by dictionary page
in this top left navigation section uh
the only other thing I'd like to point
out is that some of these terms will
have this blue play icon associated with
them and so if you click on a term that
has one of those blue icons you'll see
that you have the option to take a look
at the image you have the text
definition but then there's also a video
associated with this term and so to see
that video you can click on this blue
play icon here or here and then if you'd
like to navigate back to the image you
can click on this circle right next to
it
so that is how our biodictionary is
organized the only other organizational
piece that I'd like to talk about in the
biodictionary is this uh show option
over here right now we are displaying
all of the biodictionary terms you have
the option to see new biodictionary
terms so if you click on the new tab
there then you can see terms that have
been added within the last two months
and these we try to update our
biodictionary relatively frequently so
if you you know are a frequent user of
the site and you'd like to see if new
terms have been added within the last
two months you can click on this new
Option here the other option that you
have have is if you would like to see
terms that only terms that include
videos you can click on this video Tab
and that will bring up all of the terms
that have videos associated with the
specific terms
so the next thing that I like to talk
about is our resources Tab and this tab
is basically aggregating a lot of the
different items that we have available
within the content pieces themselves
however there are some unique items in
this resources tab such as
the first tab here which is activities
so if you click on this activities tab
you'll see that we have activities that
are associated with content pieces
or for example like the science sketch
activity is not associated with any
content piece but is unique to this
activities page itself so we will add
all the activities that are associated
with content pieces but additional
activities as well can live on this page
so if you'd like to view an activity you
can just click on the icon here it will
give a brief description of the author
of the activity and then a summary of
what the activity is then you have the
option to go see the activity via this
go to activity button and it's organized
with this similar
um navigation as the narratives and key
experiments with the Explorers compass
on the left and then you can see any
media associated in this activity in
that left-hand navigation panel as well
the next thing we'll go through is our
videos page so this is our video archive
and this page includes
um all of the videos that are included
in any of our content pieces but again
like activities it also includes several
videos that are unique to the video
archive as well so if you're interested
in just browsing all the videos that we
have you can access them through this
page and you'll see it starts with the
video of the day that's the same video
that is on the home page and that
rotates daily
you can navigate through this video page
either by category we have multiple
different categories of videos for
example videos that are associated with
the bio dictionary whiteboard videos
educational activity videos any of these
different
um
headings you can navigate directly to
and see all of the videos that are
within that heading you can also search
for keywords so for example if you're
interested in seeing videos that the
word Gene is included in the title
then you will type in Gene and it will
automatically pull up any video that has
Gene included in the title of that video
next we have the PDFs and like I said on
the summary page of any of the content
pieces you'll be able to download the
PDF for that piece we also have all of
the PDFs for all of the pieces
aggregated together on this page so you
can download the PDFs for all of our
content pieces via this page and that is
the same thing for guided papers we have
a page where all of the guided papers
for all of the all of the content pieces
are brought together for easy access for
users
in addition we have slides
um these are a slide deck that the x-bio
team has created for each one of the
content pieces Educators can use these
uh in any way they like for lectures for
study guides or anything like that
Learners can use these to help them
study for tests or just learn a little
bit more about the visuals involved in
any of the
content pieces and you can see that you
can download these in two different
formats you can either download them in
PowerPoint or in Keynote
um you can navigate through these by
collection so either cell biology or
genetics you can also look at these uh
by narrative or key experiments or all
of the content pieces put together
the final thing in this resources tab is
the newsletter archive
and this is a uh just an archive of all
of the newsletters that we have sent out
up to the
last newsletter that we have sent out
and this is basically just for a
reference so if you are on our
newsletter and you remember us saying
something within a newsletter but you
can't find it within your email or
something all of the newsletters are
brought together on this page so you can
view those there and you can also
download those as well if you'd like to
so the next thing we will move on to is
the groups functionality which I
mentioned briefly earlier so if you are
an educator you can create a group
within the xbiosite and then invite
other Learners or even other Educators
to join that group and the benefit of
groups is you can once you've created a
group and you can create a new group uh
just with this create new group tab you
can manage the group uh with these two
different tabs here
um but once you've created a group you
can share announcements with your group
so for example if you have announcements
if you have a class that you have
invited to all of your students to join
on you can post announcements here you
can start group discussions so you can
create a new discussion and group
members can go back and forth in the
discussion section here
and then as I mentioned you can share
specific collections with your group so
see I've shared one of my collections
this General collection with this group
so all of the Learners in this group
will be able to take a look at this
collection and then you can also share
specific content so for example I've
added several of the content pieces here
um and you can do that by clicking this
share X bio contents
or share collections for the collections
and again you can edit the group details
here you can manage the group members
here
um and then invite uh by to invite folks
that's this manage members tab will be
how you invite folks and you just add
their email address here that will be
sent an email to join the group uh they
have the option not to join the group if
they don't want to and then once you
have added those you can just click edit
members and Save
the next thing that I'll go through
um or that I just want to mention I'm
not actually going to go through all
these is the about X biotab
um this has just more information on the
project on the content and on the team
uh Forex bio we also have a new text Bio
Section to highlight things that have
recently been added to the site I'll
allow folks to explore that at their
Leisure this this section is more just
for providing more information about the
project the team and the content
um so the next thing I will go through
is the information for Learners tab so
this you can see there are multiple
sections to this tab but this section is
uh to allow Learners to
[Music]
um
learn how to explore the sites so if you
click on this for Learners tab or
information for Learners there's some
information about the project there's
some information about the content
there's a little bit of information
about the functionalities that Learners
can use on the site there's also a
written learner guide that you can
navigate to through this learner guide
tab so you can download the pdf version
of learner guide and that provides much
of the details that are covered on this
page but in much more depth and detail
they also there's also a groups tab just
to let Learners know that they may they
can be in invited to groups by their
educators
and then finally there is a additional
X-File learner resources
um tab which will show them all of the
resources that we've already gone
through on the top navigation but it's
just a way for Learners to take a look
at all the different resources that we
have on the site and if they click any
of these icons or text it'll take them
directly to those pages
so similar similarly as for Learners we
have a four Educators tab this is
organized just like the four Learners
tab but it has more information for
um Educators specifically so again on
the information for educators page it
shows it demonstrates that we have
educated resources we have activities
and that they can create groups and
invite their students there
in addition we have our educator guide
which is similar to the learner guide is
a PDF that expands on a lot of the
information that is presented on this
information for educators page it goes
into that in a lot more depth and detail
uh similarly as in the Learners page we
have a brief explanation of groups and
how educators can learn more about
creating groups and then finally we have
an educator resources page which
highlights all of the different
um
resources that we have for
uh Educators specifically which includes
some of the same things like PDFs and
guided papers and videos that Learners
will see but also has descriptions of
our active learning activities and
slides and educator assessment questions
as well as practice questions here at
the bottom
thanks very much and we hope you enjoyed
the orientation